hay mucha incertidumbre en torno al
resultado que escenario indican las
encuestas sobre este resultado y qué
papel pueden jugar los indecisos este
domingo
bueno muy buenas tardes si efectivamente
las encuestas llevan ya 120 días
diciendo que gana en la opción que
rechaza la nueva la propuesta de nueva
constitución
y en lo que se ha venido viendo es de
que es a la distancia entre la prueba y
el rechazo se ha mantenido más o menos
estable en el último tiempo y están
pronosticando las últimas tres encuestas
publicadas privadamente porque hace 15
días que tenemos prohibición de
publicación de encuestas
dicen que iba a ganar el rechazo por 10
puntos sin embargo
ni la bolsa de comercio ni el valor del
dólar
han ido reflejando esta confianza de que
podría rechazar esta constitución salvo
el hace dos o tres días que empezó a
bajar el valor del dólar si en este
tiempo se ha hablado mucho de la campaña
en contra de la constitución cómo ha
sido esa campaña y que se argumenta en
contra del texto
bueno es que la campaña más sucia que ha
tenido chile desde el año 90 es una
campaña donde la verdad dejó de existir
y se empezaron a fabricar las verdades
falsa la face news que no sé es
curiosamente se instaló de parte del
rechazo a través de la face news tres
temas que afectan mucho al mundo popular
uno es que a la gente le van a quitar su
casa dos que a la gente le van a quitar
el agua para regar los campos y tres que
le van a quitar el dinero que tienen
acumulados en los fondos de pensiones
siendo que esta constitución es una
constitución que garantiza derechos
sociales y esa es una de las mayores
demandas del estallido social entonces
él rechazó la campaña del rechazo ha
instalado a través de estas
genius no es cierto la idea de que estos
tres temas centrales
digamos producen exactamente el efecto
contrario que es lo que la nueva
constitución traje
así que ahí es donde se se se corre la
carrera la carrera si corren esos tres
temas esos son los temas que hacen que
hoy día una parte importante de el mundo
popular esté votando rechazo sin la
crítica general habla de ideologización
del texto cree usted posible que la
constitución de un país nos refleje el
marco ideológico preponderante de la
sociedad en el momento de su
implementación
bueno chile es una sociedad
terriblemente tradicional y la nueva
constitución es una constitución
vanguardista que aborda los temas del
futuro de la humanidad como es el tema
de la globalización el tema de el cambio
climático del colapso climático etcétera
y eso evidentemente es un tema difícil
de comprender para una sociedad
tradicional y por lo tanto hemos hemos
con eso se ha producido una exacerbación
del conservadurismo la gente quiere
cambios pero no necesariamente ese nivel
de modernidad ahí hay un rechazo también
a una sociedad más ser más
materialista que yo sé que no sé que no
se refleja completamente
digamos en el mundo más popular